why should you deprive yourself from
having muffins when you know that you
can big super healthy and delicious
muffins hey guys it's Jenna here I bet
you're watching this video because you
love muffins but just like me you
wouldn't want to get a muffin top from
eating them so I want to share with you
my favorite muffin recipes which I like
to have for breakfast or even as a
pre-workout snack not two banana muffins
chocolate peanut butter muffins and of
course cranberries zucchini muffins I
absolutely love these recipes because
they're so easy and quick to put
together and of course you can make them
ahead so on a busy day just have a quick
breakfast bite or hit them on the girl
these recipes are great for vegans we
won't be using any butter sugar flour or
eggs another great thing about these
muffins is that they all start with the
same pattern so you can pretty much add
anything you like to the mix each recipe
makes six muffins so let's start by
making the egg replacement in a small
bowl mix 1 tablespoon of chia seeds with
3 tablespoons of water
allow the mix to sit for about 5 minutes
until it becomes pudding like similar to
raw egg yolk now we want to make the
basic batter in illegible
I'm going to add all the dry ingredients
so 3/4 cup of oats flour you can choose
to use amma flour or any other flower of
your choice so that I'm going to add
quarter teaspoon of baking soda combined
well in another bowl I'm going to add
all the wet ingredients half a cup of
soy milk again you can choose any other
milk of your choice then we want to add
2 tablespoons of maple syrup or honey 1
tablespoon of coconut oil 1/2 a teaspoon
of vanilla extract and the chair mixture
or if you're not a vegan you can
replaced the char mixture with an egg
mix well to make the better we want to
combine it in wet and dry ingredients so
that's the base of your batter which you
can then add any ingredients you like so
let's start by making the Nazi banana
muffins we want to add two medium
sliced bananas into the wet mixture
roughly mash them up using a fork you
want to make sure your bananas are extra
ripe to really get the natural sweetness
from the fruit don't worry about the
chunks it gives extra texture to the
muffins then we want to combine the dry
and wet ingredients and I'm going to add
about three tablespoons of crush our
nuts into the mix again you can choose
any other nuts or seeds of your choice
scoop the batter into six muffin tins
and I'm going to top them up with a
little more crushed almond nuts just for
presentation then bake in a preheated
oven at 180 degrees Celsius or 350
degrees Fahrenheit for just about 15
minutes and to a toothpick inserted
comes out clean once they are done your
house will smell of freshly baked
muffins if you love the crunchy texture
of nut you will love this recipe every
bite you take is filled with a Menards
and the sweetness of bananas allow them
to cool down for about five to ten
minutes before serving next chocolate
peanut butter muffins so we want to add
quite a cup of unsweetened cocoa powder
into the dry ingredients and two
tablespoons of peanut butter into the
wet ingredients combine the dry and wet
ingredients and finally stir in the
chocolate chips
again scoop the batter into six muffin
tins then bake them in a preheated oven
for about 15 minutes
chocolate lovers this recipe is for you
this muffin is really rich with cocoa
and everybody take you will bite into
the melted chocolate chips I have to say
this is one of my favorite ways to
indulge in chocolate especially for
breakfast and finally let's make the
cranberry zucchini muffins so start by
mixing the basic wet and dry ingredients
together then we want to simply add 1
cup of grated zucchini and cut a cup of
dried cranberries into the batter stir
well to make sure that all the
ingredients are well combined if at all
you're better gets too thick you can add
about 2 tablespoons of water into the
mix you know the next step we want to
scoop the batter into 6 muffin tins and
bake them in a preheated oven for about
15 minutes having this muffin for
breakfast is a great way to add more
vegetables into your diet so these are
all really basic muffin recipes which
you can change and adapt to your liking
they are not going to be overly sweet if
you like your muffins to be sweeter you
can add more maple syrup or honey or
even apple sauce into the mix I prefer
them this way because I like to spread
jam honey or even peanut butter onto the
muffins the cherries will give the
muffin a slight pudding-like texture so
it's crunchy on the outside
about moist on the inside I like to call
these super muffins because they are
packed with good nutrients good calories
and they are good for your body and guys
I want you to get into your kitchen and
start baking these super muffins don't
forget to snap pictures and share them
with me on your Instagram and Facebook
check me at Jonas on official if you
love these muffins then give this video
a thumb up share it and subscribe to my
youtube channel for new weekly videos
you watch my recommended videos right at
the end for more breakfast recipes all
the best
you
you